hi hello what are you all doing here
we're on a blind date so hold on hold on
hold on hold on it's a double blind date
yeah
so on one side if they take they only
know each other they're dating the other
side yeah okay
[Music]
what was the last porn video you watched
oh so I like to support local black
businesses
so the last point that I watched was
only fans
delivery was amazing it was exquisite
that's the best way to say you watch and
pay for porn I imagine support my local
black businesses you know so I'm helping
out I'm a economist like just her
walking around in her dirty bedroom just
taking up throwing clothes
I think he's like nah she was doing way
nasty or [ __ ] but sure yeah yeah
he's walking around I wasn't in the room
that was nasty and you paying for that
terrible I'm embarrassed but I searched
10 inch dick I have never seen a 10 inch
dick they went they went
you see that in this house
I said certified freestyles seven days a
week
ass
well you're not gonna find it here if
you guys are enjoying today's video make
sure you leave a like and a comment help
us out with that algorithm push the
video to everybody that's how you can do
it just smash it okay I'm embarrassed
but I um searched 10 inch dick I have
never seen a 10 inch dick foreign
did you find what you were looking for
yes
on a scale from one to ten how gay are
you well I'm bi same says okay okay I
think I'm gonna do six because I
actually would date somebody same kind
of thing but only recently have I
actually wanted to like try dating yeah
I'm gonna go with the four I've been
told that I am a pillow princess gay
what is that like you'll make out with a
woman but you won't go any further I'll
make out with a woman I'll let her do
things to me but I'm not doing it to her
ah if that's a four man I'm like a
negative two I'm gonna say I'm a two
because I'm like okay boots if they
welcome okay hair flip a man a man you
don't know dude be having extensions I
think you were more than a two
foreign
look at the body look at the body
language right here look look am I
missing something from this episode are
there secret gays here
because I'm gonna be honestly a lot of
them did give me gay Vibes yeah I
thought it was I thought it was that I I
thought they I thought they were
yeah well that hearing is super
okay he's going to sleep no no
no time what do you do I mean it's more
like if he wanted a kiss to good night
I'd be like bro okay friend yeah round
it up to two we're gonna round that up
we can call it a three what's happening
what the [ __ ] is happening what the [ __ ]
no no what the [ __ ] is happening that's
not a two am I a lost here on what on a
scale of what to what one to two are
they pranking these girls is it on the
scale of zero to two no no no [ __ ]
Birdman this [ __ ] don't care on a scale
of what
on a scale once again that's gay
definitely okay I'm not mad I'm just
confused I thought this was dates but
rounding it up to what solid one so you
wouldn't kiss him
all right for my homies I'll I'll line
up with him
[Music]
that's not a double date that's not a
double date it's fine it's fine if
you're gay but I mean that's not a
double what is happening it's not a
double date so if you guys think I watch
it I have no idea what's happening it's
not a double date it's just who gave us
not that's what it is
do your best [ __ ] impersonation
made these questions
if that's what you think these are
questions for blind date they're not
let's do this let's go
no
rip it around the lips you know you're
just gonna go with the quick kiss you
don't know
this [ __ ] went dead girl that's
not how you do it
no no
put around and lips you know just gonna
go with the quick kiss we don't know
what's this guy's face he's like he's
changing from gate to not gay he's like
yes girl uh
sucked at that look at look hold up
that's what you pay attention
just just kiss
[Music]
why this is the most toughest thing I've
ever seen tell me why your friend is
still single he's a world traveler he's
a dancer performer can speak another
language it's a little intimidating
that's what it is she has not met anyone
to match her fly I'm ready for that
challenge yeah I don't have a lot of
time I'ma figure it out
it's a wrap
it out I'm gonna eat that [ __ ] I'm
gonna beat it up all night like this
who would you marry [ __ ] and kill it's a
dangerous question
oh a shot I don't believe in marriage so
you wouldn't get married it's like me
with kids wait you don't want kids
either
it's the same way with marriage
I'm gonna be a little scary but I got
you take a shot
bow shot right I'll take it [ __ ] her you
know I got that what bile shot cause one
I'm not in a day with you and [ __ ] you
put me in lashes ugliest boom [ __ ] her
bow I don't like you you you're the
prize I didn't even know you that well
to say I want to marry you I do got the
rings on fine you want to be married
sure we know Misha is not down with girl
so I guess I'll [ __ ] you oh but then
that leaves yeah I'm dead but you gonna
go to heaven girl you're gonna be with
God you tell this girl
she's on the baby you know you know you
good she made me sound like getting
married like yeah whatever [ __ ] let's
get married sounds like her parents
actually I'm Buddhist and I will be here
again so don't try to bring me to your
Heaven well listen I'm gonna bring her
back for another good life I [ __ ] with
the philosopher I know who I'm gonna
marry wait I think I was supposed to ask
them the question and not answer about
the way it went do your best eating the
Box impression
I want to see this
oh
[Applause]
shall I continue
this is so weird he's going
oh
[Applause]
that [ __ ] took your temple out
foreign
out who do you think has the bigger
penis
and why do y'all know who got the bigger
thing yeah y'all best friends who got
the bigger thing we not like how girls
be black girl show me yours okay okay
sis I don't think I've ever done that
okay have y'all ever done that okay I
see you out here
what size shoe do you wear 11 and a half
what size
I don't want to see
because
we already know the answer
we have the bigger penis yeah
pause which person at the table would
you leave out of a threesome we're
definitely he hadn't done anything
we I mean I mean what do you
you getting left behind dog I'm sorry
yes you kiss me good night but you
couldn't smash the same girl isn't it I
can't see your dick Eiffel towering is
the
distance
yo what is happening right now this is
this is one of the weirdest gays
Dynamics I've ever seen here
you know what it seems like this is this
is what it seems like this is what it
seems like
This Is What It Seems like to me on the
outside looking in the guy on the left
is gay the guy on the right is bisexual
and there's some weirdness going on
agreed just talking about and something
and something already happened between
them
kissing each other good night what what
yeah no I'm sorry I want these two I
wanna [ __ ] training
I want a human centipede there you go no
you don't know
that's when the shots are getting to
your friend
do you know what a human centipede is
like you're eating a whole lot of ass
while you get your ass eaten
they were literally I know
[ __ ] I know and then I don't know what
are you missing to be this
I've taken time to do early search to
find out what a human centipede is
it is deviant therefore it is a sickness
we do not want it which of us would you
take on a real date take my husband home
and we we're gonna do our own thing we
get it to win it I would take siraj
I like your Vibe you have a nice smile
thank you I would say
you could you seem fun which one of us
would you take on a real date I would
take you on a date for sure oh yeah so
where are you taking her there's this
place in White Center called Crawfish
House we could go as long as you don't
judge me because I do like getting messy
no let's do it okay because let's do it
do you like eat your hands yeah just
like I have it all over my face and I
want you to wipe it off I'll lick it off
you know the cut just tries to find a
generative regenerate things
this channel I don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening I don't know what I just
watched what their orientations were
that was confusing what's happening very
confusing but yeah you know what the
winner today the closet so
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below I'm out